this is Jaco podcasts number 103 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening whilst lying
at Winchester young as I was in the
profession I was picked out amongst
others to perform a piece of duty that
for many years afterwards remain deeply
impressed upon my mind and gave me the
first impression of the stern duties of
a soldier's life a private of the
seventieth regiment had deserted from
that Corps and afterwards enlisted into
several other regiments indeed I was
told at the time that sixteen different
times he had received the bounty and
then stolen off being however caught at
last he was brought to trial at
Portsmouth and sentenced by general
court-martial to be shot as the
execution would be a good hint to us
youngins there were four lads picked out
of our Corps to assist in this piece of
Duty myself being one of the number
chosen
besides these men four soldiers from
three other regiments were ordered on
the firing party making 16 at all the
place of execution was ports downhill
and the different regiments assembled
must have composed a force of about
15,000 men having been assembled from
the Isle of Wight from Chichester Gulf
Sport and other places the sight was
very imposing and appeared to make a
deep impression on all there as for
myself I felt that I would have given a
good round sum had I possessed it to
have been in any other situation rather
than one rather than the one which I now
found myself and when I looked into the
faces of my companions I saw by the
pallor and anxiety anxiety depicted in
each countenance
the reflection of my own feelings when
all was ready we were moved to the front
and the culprit was brought out he made
a short speech to the parade
acknowledging the Justice of his
sentence and that drinking and evil
company had brought the punishment upon
him he behaved himself firmly and well
and did not seem to flinch at all after
being blindfolded he does he was desired
to kneel down behind a coffin which was
placed on the ground and the drum major
of the Depot giving us an expressive
glance we immediately commenced to
loading this was done in the deepest
silence
and the next moment we were primed and
ready there was then a dreadful pause
for a few moments and the drum major
again looking towards us gave us the
signal agreed upon before a flourish of
his cane and we leveled and fired
we had been previously strictly and
joined to be steady and take good aim
and the poor fellow pierced by several
balls fell heavily upon his back as he
lay with his arms pinion to his side's I
observed that his hands waved for a few
moments like the fins on a fish winning
the Agony's of death the drum major also
observed the movement and making another
signal for of our party immediately
stepped up to the posture a body and
placing the muzzles of their pieces to
the head fired and put him out of his
misery the different regiments then fell
back by companies and the word being
given to march passed in slow time when
each company came in line with the body
the word was given to mark
and then eyes left in order that we all
might observe the terrible example we
then moved on words and marched from the
ground to our different quarters and
that is from a book called recollections
of rifleman Harris who was an enlisted
soldier for the British Army during the
Napoleonic Wars and that was his welcome
to the army
he'd been in for about three weeks of
service when he had to stand and execute
a fellow soldier for basically being
drunk and disorderly not doing what he
was supposed to do essentially he was
being executed for being a human being
and that was the introduction to
military service for rifleman Harris
rifleman Harris's full name was Benjamin
Randall Harris he enlisted in 1803 he
fought all over Europe in the Peninsular
war which posed bourbon Spain the
Kingdom of Portugal and the British
Empire against Napoleon's French Empire
and Bonaparte as' Spain and also the
Duchy of Warsaw and this is a war where
they have daggers and swords and
bayonets and mounted cavalry charges
they have cannons and they used a lot of
muzzle loading rifles which a skilled
riflemen could load and fire about three
times per minute accurate out to about
two hundred yards
very different from the weapons that we
have now which can fire three rounds in
a second and are very accurate out to
800 yards a thousand yards and some
sniper weapons way further than that but
even though these weapons are different
from the weapons we see in modern
warfare as always in the end it is men
it is human beings on the battlefield
bleeding sweating starving suffering
killing and being killed let's find out
a little bit more about riflemen harris
going back to the book my father was a
shepherd and i was a sheep boy from my
earliest youth indeed as soon as almost
I could run I began helping my father to
look after the sheep on the downs of
Blandford in Dorsetshire
where I was born whilst I continued to
tend the flocks and herds under my
charge and occasionally in the long
winter nights I learned the art of
making shoes I grew a hardy little chap
and was one fine day in the year of 1802
drawn as a soldier for the army of
reserve thus without troubling myself
much about the change which was about to
take place in the quiet of my routine
days I was drafted into the 66th
regiment of foot bid goodbye to my
Shepherd companions and was obliged to
leave my father without an assistant to
collect his flocks just as he was
beginning more than ever to require one
nay indeed I may say to want tending and
looking after himself for old age and
infirmary were coming on him
his hair was growing white as the sleet
of our downs and his countenance
becoming as furrowed as the ploughed
fields around
however as I had no choice in the matter
it was quite as well that I did not
grieve over my fate my father tried hard
to buy me off and would have persuaded
the sergeant of the 66th that I was of
no use as a soldier from having maimed
my right hand by breaking the forefinger
when I was a child
the sergeant however said I was just the
sort of little chap he wanted and off he
went
carrying me amongst a batch of recruits
he had collected away with him sheep
herder
mmm-hmm dads getting old army comes and
gets you that's the way it works
England 1802 now he travels around a
little bit and eventually ends up in
Dublin and here we go back to the book
walleston Dublin I one day saw a core of
the 95th rifles and fell so in love with
their smart dashing and devil-may-care
appearance that nothing would serve me
until I was a rifleman myself so on
arriving at Castle one day and falling
in with the recruiting party of that
regiment I volunteered into the second
Battalion
this recruiting party were all Irishmen
and I and had been sent over from
England to collect amongst others men
from the Irish militia and were just
about to return to England I think they
were as reckless and devil-may-care a
set of men I had ever been beheld either
before or since
so these these riflemen I would say from
what I read about them there they're
almost like a special ops unit and one
big difference is they're wearing
instead of wearing red jackets like the
Brits would wear at this time they wore
green so they were a little bit
different and they had more accurate
rifles and they would fight they would
do what they called skirmishing which is
is fundamentally cover move they'd shoot
and they'd maneuver and they'd they'd
they'd act like little Special
Operations troops out there and of
course it's interesting to me and when I
hear this guy talking about the first
time he saw someone that looked a little
bit like a Special Operations Troop he
said he actually says I fell in love you
know that's that's very much how I felt
as I was growing up the more I saw you
know the Special Ops II actually didn't
even need to be special ops for me it
was just someone in the military but
then he was already in the military so
now he's looking for the next thing
what's the next thing gonna be and here
he ends up as a rifleman so he's now a
rifleman he joins he moves over to their
regiment and here we go back to the book
the next day we marched for Ashford and
Kent where I joined the 95th rifles and
about six months after my joining four
companies of the second battalion were
ordered on the expedition to Denmark we
embarked at deal and sailing for hostile
Shores landed on a little place called I
think scarlet island the expedition
consisted of about 30,000 men and at the
moment of our getting on shore the whole
force set up one simultaneous and
tremendous cheer a sound I cannot
describe it seemed so inspiring this
indeed was the first time of my hearing
the style in which our men give tongue
when they get near the enemy though
afterwards my ears became pretty well
accustomed to such sounds as soon as we
got on shore the rifles were pushed
pushed forward and he says the rifles
he's talking about his guys the rifles
were pushed forward as the advance in
chain order through some thick woods of
fur and when we had cleared these woods
and approached Copenhagen centuries were
posted on the roads and openings leading
toward the town in order to intercept
all comers and prevent all supplies such
posts were occupied for about three days
and nights whilst the town was being
fired upon by our shipping I rather
think this was the first time of the
Congreve rockets being brought into play
and they rushed through the air in the
dark they appeared so
like so many fiery serpents creating I
should think
terrible dismay among the the siege the
Congreve rockets they they basically
look like giant bottle rockets in a way
and and they got at this time they were
getting their range out to 1500 2000
meters so it was a pretty crazy weapon
and and I can tell you rockets in this
day and age have become fairly accurate
but in those days probably about as
accurate as a bottle rocket is my guess
back to the book as the main army came
up we advanced and got as near under the
walls of the place as we could without
being endangered by the fire from our
own shipping so what's happening right
there is cover move the shipping is
bombarding and these guys are advancing
as close as they can where they were not
gonna get killed by their own by their
own fire from the ships we now received
orders ourselves to commence firing
and the rattling of the guns I shall not
easily forget I felt so much exhilarated
that I could hardly keep back and was
checked by the commander of the company
who called me by my name to keep my
place about this time my front rank man
a tall fellow named Jack Johnson showed
a disposition as though the firing had a
effect on him the reverse of what it had
had on many others of the company for he
seemed inclined to hang back and once or
twice turned round in my face I was a
rear rank man and porting my piece in
the excitement of the moment I swore
that if he did not keep his ground I
would shoot him dead on the spot
so that he found it he would go on so
that he found it would be quite as
dangerous for him to return as to go on
I feel sorry to record the want of
courage of this man but I do so with the
less pain it gives me the opportunity of
saying that during my many years of
arduous service is the only instance I
remember of a British soldier
endeavoring to hold back when his
comrades were moving forward indeed
Johnson was never held begin an
estimation among the rifle corps for the
story got wind that I had threatened
shoot him for cowardice in the field and
lieutenant Cox mentioned to the colonel
that he'd overheard my doing so and such
was the contempt the man was held in by
the rifles that he was soon afterwards
removed there you go first time under
fire it's it's interesting how rifleman
Harris first time under fire he wants to
get after he is ready to charge and only
one guy out of their whole crew is
looking like he's gonna hold back and
they talk about reputation here and
that's definitely something that is it
when you get to the SEAL Teams as you're
a new guy someone tells you they'll say
hey your reputation is everything and
it's totally true and it's the same in
any military organization what your
reputation is because because in the
military you think ranks all important
right yeah but but the reality is
there's something that completely
Trump's rank and that's reputation if
you and and if you're I mean I always
talk about the fact that relationships
are more important than chain of command
but you're not gonna have a good
relationship with people if you don't
have a good reputation it's not
happening yeah so make sense
same thing back in 1803 back to the book
walleston Denmark we led a tolerably
active life the rifles being continually
on the alert ordered hither today and
countermanded the next occasionally also
we had some pleasant adventures among
the blue-eyed Danish lasses for the
rifles were always terrible fellows in
that way I think that doesn't need too
much explanation they I'll say this as I
always say they have to fast-forward
through this book I'm not reading the
entire book even though the entire book
is awesome in this point this point here
they're embarking for Purse Portugal we
have another another campaign to go on
back to the book I wish I could picture
the splendid sight of the shipping
the downs at the time we embarked with
about 20,000 men those were times which
are so which the soldiers of our own
more peaceable days have little
conception of so this book was written
before World War one mm-hmm and and
really this was the the last big war is
the Boers that he went through the
Napoleonic Wars so he's kind of he's
kind of saying you don't even know what
this is like anymore you don't know what
it's like you don't know that the the
the soldiers of our own more peaceable
days have little conception of what it's
like to embark 20,000 troops to get
ready and go get some mm back to the
book we sailed majestically out of the
cove of cork for hostile Shore where we
would safely arrived and disembarked at
Mondego Bay the rifles were first out of
the vessels for we were indeed always in
front of the advance and always in the
rear in retreat like the Kentish men of
old we claim the post of Honor in the
field I tried to figure out what that
Kentish man Kent is obviously a place
and and the as far the best I could
figure out was that the people and Kant
stood up hardcore against the Norman
invasion I think that's what that
reference is to I'm sure somebody will
correct me and I hope somebody does back
to the book being immediately pushed
forward up the country in advance the
main body many of us in this hot climate
very soon began to find out the misery
of the frightful load we were condemned
to march and fight under with a burning
Sun above our heads and our feet sinking
every step into the hot sand the weight
of the weight I myself toiled under was
tremendous and I often wonder at the
strength I possessed at this period that
which enabled me to endure it for indeed
I'm convinced that many of our infantry
sank and died under the weight of their
knapsacks alone for my own part being a
handicraft a handicraft
I marched under the weight sufficient to
impede the free motions of a donkey for
besides my well-filled kit there was the
great coat rolled
stop my blanket and camp kettle my
haversack stuffed full of leather for
repairing the men's shoes together with
a hammer and other tools ship biscuit
and beef for three days I also carried
my canteen filled with water my hatchet
rifle and eighty realms of ball
cartridge in my pouch
this last except the beef and biscuit
being the best thing I owned and which I
always gave the enemy the benefit of
when the opportunity offered it's it's
interesting he knew how to work on shoes
and so he carries stuff to repair shoes
in the field mmm think about that that's
just a lost art isn't it but think about
where you are in the field when you have
to march 15 miles a day and you have no
shoes if there's someone that can fix
your shoes that's that's a godsend back
to the book the next day we again
advanced and being in a state of the
utmost anxiety to come up along the
French neither the heat of the burning
Sun long miles or heavy knapsacks were
able to diminish our our ger indeed I
often look back with wonder at the light
hearted style Ligeti and the reckless
indifference with which men who were so
destined in short time to fall hurried
onwards toward the field of strife
seemingly without a thought of anything
but the sheer love of meeting the foe
and the excitement of battle he wrote
this book twenty-something years after
this happened after this experience I
want to say he wrote it in
1930-something
1938 maybe is when it came out and you
can see that so my point in saying that
is that looking back he knows cuz he's
gonna he's gonna go through hell he's
gonna go through hardcore combat but
even even knowing how horrible combat is
he still looks back in his is amazed at
how they were ready to go going back to
the book
the 29th regiment received so terrible a
fire that I saw the right wing almost
annihilated and the colonel I think his
name was Lennox lay sprawling amongst
the rest we had caught ourselves in it
pretty handsomely for there was no cover
for us and we were rather too near the
Living skirmishers were laying beside
heaps of their own dead but still we had
her own till the battalion regiments
come up fire and retire is a very good
sound but the rifles were not overfond
of such notes we never performed that
maneuver except when it was made pretty
plain to us that it was quite necessary
the 29th however had got their fairing
here at this time and the shock of that
fire seemed to stagger the whole line
and make them recoil at the moment a
little confusion appeared in the ranks I
thought Lord Hill was near at hand and
saw it and I observed him come galloping
up he put himself at the head of the
regiment and restored them to order in a
moment there's some leadership just
full-on leadership in action
so there's also fire and retire what
that means is cover and move so you have
some people shooting and some people
falling back that's how they retreat and
there they use that whenever they have
to retreat you'll hear that and in I
don't know if I did this made this clear
enough but it's a bugle it's a bugle
signal so the bugle would play some
certain number of notes or some pattern
of notes and pee and everyone would know
okay that means fine retire so now we're
now we get that broad that broad the
broad plan out to everyone at once which
is instead of advancing which is what we
were doing
now we're gonna we're gonna retreat and
as soon as you get everyone that
information now little elements can
start to make it happen that's
decentralized command but you have to
give good communications in order for
that to work and what you need to
communicate is the broad plan and that's
what they get done with a nice little
bugle signal back to the book pouring a
regular and sharp fire upon the enemy he
called them in return and remaining with
the twenty-ninth until he brought them
to the charge quickly sent the foe in
the right about
it seemed to me that few men could have
conducted the business with more
coolness and quietude of manner under
such a storm of Falls as he was exposed
to indeed I have never forgotten him
from that day so yeah it's important to
also recognize that you have a you have
a group of men that are about to fall
apart and there's confusion and one guy
and I talk about this all the time
one guy steps up takes ownership of the
situation leads and it changes the
entire outcome of the battle think about
that one person you got thousand men
versus a thousand men one person makes
the difference so if you're in a
leadership position think about that
think about what you're doing are you
leading are you stepping up are you
galloping up on a horse and setting
things right hmm cuz that's what you
need to be doing back to the book at the
time I was remarking these matters
loading and firing as I lay another
circumstance divided my attention for a
while and made me forget even the
gallant conduct of general Hill a man
near me honored a scream of agony and
looking from the twenty-ninth who were
on my right to the left
whence the screech had come I saw one of
our sergeants named Frazer sitting in a
doubled up position and swaying
backwards and forwards as though he had
got a terrible pain in his bowels he
continued to make such a complaint that
I arose and went to him for he was
rather a crony of mine Oh Harris said he
as I took him in my arms I shall die I
shall die the agony is so great that I
cannot bear it
it was indeed dreadful to look upon him
the froth came from his mouth and the
perspiration poured from his face thank
heaven he was soon out of pain and
laying him down I returned to my place
poor fellow he suffered more for a short
time that he was dying than any man I
think I ever saw in the same
circumstances I had the courtesy to
return and look at him after the battle
a musket ball I found had taken him
sideways and gone through both groins
within about a half an hour after this I
left sergeant Frazer and indeed for the
time had as completely forgotten him as
if he had died a hundred years back the
sight of so much bloodshed around will
not suffer the mind to dwell long in any
particular casualty even though it
happened to one's dearest friends there
was no time either to think for all was
action with us rifles just at this
moment and the barrel of my peace was so
hot from continual firing that I could
hardly bear to touch it and was obliged
to grasp the stock beneath the iron as I
continued to blaze away it doesn't even
have time to think about it yeah
James Ponton was another crony of mine a
gallant fellow he had pushed himself in
front of me and was checked by one of
our officers wrapped for his rashness
keep back you Ponton the lieutenant said
to him more than once but Ponton was to
be restrained but Ponton was not to be
restrained by anything but a bullet when
in action this time he got one which
striking him in the thigh I suppose hit
an artery for he died quickly the
Frenchman's balls were flying very
wickedly at that moment and I crept up
to Ponton and took shelter by lying
behind and making a rest for my rifle of
his dead body it strikes me that I
revenged his death by the assistance of
his carcass at any rate I tried my best
to hit his enemies hard there were two
small buildings to our front and the
French having managed to get into them
annoy us much from that quarter a small
rise in the ground closed before these
houses also favored them and our men
were being handled very severely in
consequence they became angry and
wouldn't stand it any longer one of the
skirmishers jumping off
forward crying over boys over over when
he instantly when instantly the whole
line responded to the cry over over over
they ran along the grass like wildfire
then dashed at the rise fixing their
sword bayonets as they ran the French
light Bob's could not stand the sight
but turned about and fled and getting
possession of their ground we were soon
inside the buildings after the battle
was over I stepped across the other
house I have mentioned in order to see
what was going on there for the one I
remained in was now pretty well filled
with the wounded both French and English
who had managed to get there for a
little shelter two or three surgeons
also had arrived at this house and were
busily engaged in giving their
assistance to the wounded now also here
lying as thickly as in the building
which I had left but what struck me the
most but what struck me the most
forcibly was that from the circumstance
of some wine busts having been left in
the apartment and having their
engagement been perforated having in the
engagement been perforated by bullets
and otherwise broken the red wine had
escaped most plentifully and ran down
upon the earth and floor where the
wounded were lying so that many of them
were soaked in the wine with which their
blood was mingled I I hate to even think
about the medical care that these guys
are getting and any of the medical care
that that we had in Iraq was
unbelievable not only from the speed
that you would get assistance but also
the quality of care that you would get
on in the field from our own medics and
how quickly they would get you to get to
you and then get you taken care of and
then get you evacuated to a full medical
facility and that that actually changed
during my time in the teams for instance
the big the biggest change
it when when I first gotten the teams it
the what we were taught was if someone
gets shot you immediately give him an IV
meaning you know a bag of fluid because
they're bleeding you got to replace that
and now the if they don't do that
automatically because your body has its
own mechanisms when it loses blood to
stop the bleeding it pulls back in the
the arteries and veins and it constricts
them and and it clots the blood that's
there and so and when you give someone
an IV the body thinks I don't need to do
that so it opens up the arteries it
opens up the veins it doesn't constrict
anything it doesn't get clots slower so
there's like one example and now that's
during my time so that's the last 25
years that that changed has taken place
so now you go back you know a hundred
and two hundred years it's totally
different totally different and they'll
talk more about that I mean the the
basic the basic plan was if you get shot
in a limb you're losing the limb that's
basically what's going on just
amputations and then nowadays they do an
incredible job of you know saving saving
limbs if they can be saved they save
them I mean they do an incredible job
all right back to the book it was on the
15th of August when we first came up
with the French and there skirmishers
immediately commenced operations by
raining a shower of balls upon us as we
advanced which we returned without delay
and I haven't said this yet but the
reason they're saying balls and said
around us because these guys are
shooting balls moving around the balls
of lead and at this point there was some
rifling head started to come about but
what they basically just consider
everything to be a ball of lead and
that's why they're not accurate that's
why they're only accurate out to 200
meters because they're not rifled like
we have the tight rifling spinning
bullets today back to the book the first
man that was hit was lieutenant Bunbury
he fell pierced through the head with a
musket ball and died almost immediately
I thought I never heard such a
tremendous noise as the fire
made on this occasion and the men on
both sides of me I could occasionally
observe we're falling fast I do not
pretend to give a description of this or
any other battle I have been present at
all I can do is tell the things which
happened immediately around me and that
I think is as much as a private soldier
can be expected to do soon afterwards
the firing commenced and we had take we
had advanced pretty close upon the enemy
taking advantage of whatever cover I
could find I threw myself behind a small
bank where I lay so secure that although
for the Frenchman's bullets fell pretty
thickly around I was enabled to knock
several over without being dislodged in
fact I fired away every round I had in
my pouch whilst laying in this spot at
length after a sharp contest we forced
them to give ground and following them
up drove them from their position in the
heights and hung up their skirts until
they made another stand and then the
game began again the rifles indeed
fought well this day and we lost many
men they seemed in high spirits and
delighted at having driven the enemy
before them Josef Kochan was by my side
loading and firing very industriously
about this period of the day thirsting
with heat in action he lifted his
canteen to his mouth here's to you old
boy he said as he took a pull at its
contents as he did so a bullet went
through the canteen and perforated his
brain killing him in a moment another
man fell close to him almost immediately
struck and up struck by a ball in the
thigh
I saw a man named Simmons struck full in
the face by a round shot and he came to
the ground a headless trunk
when the role was called after the
battle the females who missed their
husbands came along the front of the
line to inquire of the survivors whether
they knew anything about them so the
wives could travel with the soldiers and
again that just seems crazy to me right
now but that's that's the way they did
it yeah and not all of them but if they
made that decision I guess as a family
to stick together they'd get right on
board the boats and they'd they'd March
they march and they'd cover it and in
this book they they wouldn't carry the
weight but they marched alongside and go
from place to place and when the battle
is about to take place they'd hang back
and then you have the situation once the
battle is over that I'm talking about
right now amongst other names
I heard that of coach Han called in a
female voice without being replied to
the name struck me and I observed the
poor woman who had called it as she said
stopping sobbing before us and
apparently afraid to make further
enquiries about her husband no man had
answered to his name or had any given
account to give of his fate I myself had
observed him fall as related before
whilst drinking from his canteen but as
I looked at the poor sobbing creature
before me I felt unable to tell her of
his death at length
captain leach observed her and called
out to the company does any man know
what has happened to coach Han if so let
him speak out at once upon this order I
immediately related what I had seen and
told the manner of his death after a
while in this coat mrs. Kochan appeared
anxious to seek the spot where her
husband fell and in the hope of still
finding him alive asked me to accompany
her over the field she trusted
notwithstanding what I had told her to
find him yet alive do you think you
could find it said captain leach upon
being referred to I told him I was sure
I could as I had remarked many objects
whilst looking for cover during the
skirmishing go then said the captain and
show the poor woman the spot
as she seems so desirous of finding the
body I accordingly took my way over the
ground we had fought upon she following
and sobbing after me quickly reaching
the spot when her husband's body lay
pointed out to her she now discovered
soon all her hopes were in vain she
embraced a stiffened corpse and after
rising and contemplating his disfigured
face for some minutes with hands clasped
and tears streaming down her cheeks she
took a prayer book from her pocket and
kneeling down repeated this service for
the dead over the body poor woman I
pitied her much but there was no remedy
a whole new dynamic right there
continuing on back to the book it was on
the 21st of August that we commenced
fighting the Battle of the mirrow the
French came down upon us as a column and
the riflemen immediately commenced a
sharp fire upon them from whatever cover
they could get a shelter behind whilst
our canon played upon them from our rear
I saw regular lanes torn through their
ranks as they advanced which were
immediately closed up again as they
marched steadily on whenever we saw
roundshot thus go through the mass we
raised a shout of delight
that's a savage image right their ranks
of men and there's cannonballs that are
cutting lines through cutting lanes
through them yeah and you're probably
talking twenty thirty people killed each
one and the ranks just closed in around
them and that's what these guys are
seeing as this advance takes place there
continue through that battle they get
into a position for another battle going
back to the book as I looked about me
while standing and ranked and just
thought and just before the Commandant
commencement of the battle I thought it
the most imposing sight the world could
produce our lines glittering with bright
arms the stern features of the men as
they stood with their eyes fixed on
altar ibly upon the enemy the proud
colors of England floating over the
heads of the different battalions and
the dark cannon on the rising ground and
all in readiness to commence the awful
work of death with the noise that would
definite
although the site had a singular and
terrible effect upon the feelings of a
youth who a few short months before had
been a solitary shepherd upon the downs
of Dorsetshire
and it never contemplated any other sort
of life than the peaceful occupation of
watching the innocent sheep as they fed
upon the grassy turf talk about a
dichotomy ya know fought in his mind
other than watching sheep eat grass yeah
I would think that that'd be kind of a
good little escape you know from time to
time to notice those types of things yes
I think you're right and I think that
happens in you there's a movie called
The Thin Red Line mm-hmm and that's
portrayed very well in all this chaos
he'll take cover and he'll be face to
face with a flower or will notice a bird
or a bug and that's definitely that's
definitely something that people notice
I mean I noticed there's the sunset no
matter where you are in the world yeah
and actually the sunset in the desert
it's a very beautiful thing yeah and
same with the sunrise and so those are
little things that you notice even
though you might not be in the mindset
to notice them and still notice them
mm-hmm
back to the book the battle commencing
immediately we were all soon hard at
work the rifles as usual were pretty
busy in this battle the French in great
numbers came steadily down upon us and
we pelted away upon them like a shower
of leaden hail under any cover we could
find in May
firing one moment jumping up and running
for it the next and when we could see
before us
we observe the cannonballs making a lane
through the enemy's columns as they
advanced as they were a song and
shouting like Mad Men the battle soon
became general the smoke thickened
around and often I was obliged to stop
firing and - and aside from my face and
try in vain to get a sight of what was
going on
whilst groans and shouts and a noise of
cannon and musketry appeared almost to
shake the very ground
it seemed hell upon earth I thought a
man named John Lowe stood before me at
this moment and he turned round during a
pause and our exertions then he
addressed me Harris you humbug he said
you've got plenty of money about you I
know for you're always staying about and
picking up what you can find on the
field but I think this will be your last
field day old boy a good many of us will
catch it I suspect today you're right
low I said I've got nine guineas in my
pack and if I am shot today and you
escape yourself it's quite at your
service in the meantime however if you
see any symptoms of my wishing to flinch
in this business I hope you will shoot
me with your own hand low it's too low
so let's think about that that's that's
pretty awesome first of all the attitude
of they're basically talking smack to
each yeah classic hey I don't think
you're gonna make it I got a lot of
money on you and if you don't make it
what do you say is that mine yes if I
die come and get it I got nine guineas
in my pack they're all yours and then
this is classic by the way if you see me
acting cowardly in any way you better
shoot me yeah it's legit
low as well as myself survived this
battle and after it was over whilst we
sat down with our comrades and rested
amongst other matters talked over Lowe
told them of our conversation during the
heat of the day and the money I had
collected and the rifles from that time
to time had a great respect for me
it is indeed singular how a man loses or
gains caste
his comrades from the behavior and how
closely is he is observed on the
battlefield again talking about
reputation once again the officers too
are commented upon and closely observed
everyone's watching the officers the men
are very proud of those who are brave in
the field and kind and considerate to
the soldiers and under them an act of
kindness done by an officer has often
during battle been the cause of his life
being saved that little relationship
going hmm
nay whatever folks may say upon the
matter I know from experience that in
our army the men like best be officered
by gentlemen men whose education has
rendered them more kind in manners than
your course officer sprung from obscure
origin and whose style is brutal and
overbearing so as I was reading through
that I at first I kind of got a little
bit taken aback said oh what are you
trying to say if you haven't been to
college or you that that's what you need
you'd be from this good upbringing but
that's not well that that might be what
he's saying at that time but the
important part is it's how you treat
people it doesn't matter what background
you came from you know he says men whose
education has rendered them more kind in
manners and rather than someone that's
from an obscure origin what I'm telling
you is it doesn't matter where you're
from and he would agree with this now if
he was here to talk with me but it's not
he's talking about VP the men like to
work for officers that aren't brutal and
overbearing no one likes that and you
don't perform well you want to build the
relationship with your troops the
kindness done by an officer as often
during the battle been the cause of his
life being saved that means guys are
trying to win yeah back to the book and
let me bear testimony to the courage and
endurance of the of that army under
trials and hardships such as few armies
in any age I should think in dirt
I've seen officers and men hobbling
forward with tears in their eyes from
the misery of long miles empty stomachs
and ragged backs without even shoes or
stockings on their bleeding feet and it
was not a little thing that would bring
a tear into the eyes of a rifleman of
the Peninsular wars youths who had not
long been removed from their parents
home and care officers and men have
borne hardships and privations such as
in our more peaceful days we have little
conception of and yet these men faint
and weary with toil would brighten up in
a moment when the word grant amongst us
that the enemy were at hand once again
he's ragged on you you haven't really
been to war lately peaceful days and
brutal privations that these guys go
through and yet they're still ready to
step up back to the book it was just at
the close of the battle the dreadful
turmoil and noise the engagement had
hardly subsided and I began to look at
the faces of the men close around me to
see who would escape the dangers of the
hour I saw that the ranks of the
riflemen looked very thin it seemed to
me that one half had gone down we had
four companies with a 95th and were
commanded that day by major Travers he
was a man much liked by the men of the
rifles and indeed deservedly beloved by
all who knew him
he was a tight hand but a soldier likes
that better than a slovenly officer pay
attention to that one don't be a Slaven
Lee leader they the the troops prefer
the tight hand back to the book I had
observed him more than once during this
day spurring here and there keepin the
men well up and apparently in the
highest spirits he could not have
enjoyed himself more I am sure if he had
been at a horse race or following a good
pack of hounds the battle was just over
a flag of truce came came over from the
Shh we threw ourselves down or we were
standing when the fire ceased a
Frenchman lay close beside me he was
dying and called to me for water which I
understood him to require more from his
manner than his words I need not say
that I got up and gave it to him whilst
I did so down galloped the major in
front just in the same good spirits he'd
been in all day plugging along avoiding
with some little difficulty the dead and
dying which were strewn about he was
never a very good-looking man being hard
featured and thin a hatchet-faced man as
we used to say but he was a regular
Gooden a real English soldier and that's
better than if he had been the
handsomest ladies man in the army legit
totally legit back to the book of French
a French soldier was lying beside me at
this time he was badly wounded and
hearing him moan as he lay after I had
done looking at the cavalry I turned my
attention to him and getting up lifted
his head and poured some water into his
mouth he was dying fast but he thanked
me in a foreign language which although
I did not exactly understand I could
easily make out by the look he gave me
Mullens of the rifles who stepped up
whilst I supported his head damned me
for a fool for my pains better knock out
his brains heresy said he's done us
mischief enough I'll be bound for it
today so rifleman Harris is still a
pretty sympathetic dude back to the book
towards evening I posted upon a rising
ground amongst a clump of tall trees
there seemed to have been a sharp
skirmish here as three Frenchmen were
lying dead amongst the long grass upon
the spot where I was standing as I threw
my rifle to my shoulder and walked past
them on my beat I observed they had been
plundered and their haversacks having
been torn off some of the contents were
scattered about war is a sad blunter of
the feeling
I have often thought since those days
the contemplation of three ghastly
bodies in this lonely spot failed then
in making the slightest impression upon
me the site had become even in the short
time I had been engaged in the trade but
too familiar and now there another truce
kind of happens and he's observing the
scene in this churchyard the scene in
this churchyard was somewhat singular
two long tables had been procured from
some houses near and were placed
end-to-end amongst the graves and upon
them were laid the men whose limbs it
was found necessary to amputate both
French and English were constantly
lifted on and off these tables as soon
as the operation was performed upon one
lot they were carried off and in those
waiting behind or hoisted up the
surgeons with their sleeves turned up
and their hands and arms covered in
blood looking like butchers in the
shambles I saw as I passed at least
twenty legs lying on the ground many of
them being clothed than the long black
gaiters then worn by the infantry line
the surgeons had plenty of work on hand
that day and not having the time to take
the clothes off the wounded they merely
ripped the seams and turned the cloth
back proceeding with the operation as
fast as they could
many of the wounded came straggling into
this churchyard in search of assistance
by themselves
I saw one man faint with loss of blood
staggering along and turned to assist
him he was severely wounded in the head
his face being completely encrusted with
blood which had flowing during the night
now dried one eyeball was knocked out of
the socket and hung down upon his cheek
another man I observed who had been
brought in and propped up against a
grave mount he seemed very badly hurt
the men who had carried him into the
churchyard had placed his cap filled
with the fragments of biscuit close
beside his head and
lay and and occasionally turned his
mouth towards it got a hold of a piece
of biscuit and munched it as I was about
to leave the churchyard dr. Ridgeway one
of the surgeons called me back to assist
with holding a man he was endeavoring to
operate upon come and help me with this
man he said or I shall be all day
cutting a ball out of his shoulder the
patient's name was doubter an Irishman
he disliked the doctors efforts and
writhed and twisted so much during the
operation that it was with difficulty
dr. Ridgeway could perform it he found
it necessary to cut very deep and
doubter made a terrible outcry at every
fresh incision Oh doctor dear doctor he
said it's murdering me you are blood and
hounds I shall die I shall die for the
love of the Lord don't cut me all to
pieces doubter was not altogether wrong
for although he survived the operation
he died shortly thereafter from the
effects of his wounds again you just got
surgeons mixing blood and not clean and
not even cutting off clothes or
sterilizing I mean the amount of people
that must have lost from the infections
after the fact is just crazy
now they weren't fighting all the time
and at this point they are quartered in
a house in Spain and again Spain was
divided at the time and there was
friendly and enemy Span Spain and so
they're quartered in a house and there's
a family there and here we go to the
book the mistress of the house seeing
that I was the head man occasionally
came down and sat beside me as I worked
bringing her daughter a very handsome
dark eyed Spanish girl and as a matter
of course I fell in love we soon became
better acquainted and the mother one
evening having sat and chattered to me
serving me with wine other good things
on my rising to leave the shop made a
signal for me to follow her she had
managed to pick up a little English and
I knew a few words of Spanish language
so that we could pretty well comprehend
each other's meeting and after leading
me into their sitting-room she brought
in her handsome daughter and without
more circumstance offered her to me for
a wife the offer was a tempting one but
the conditions of the marriage made it
impossible for me to comply since I was
to change my religion and desert my
colors the old dame proposed to conceal
me effectually when the army marched
after which I was to live like a
gentleman
with the handsome Maria for a wife it
was hard to refuse so tempting an offer
with pretty Maria endeavoring to back
her mother's proposal I however made
them understand that nothing would tempt
me to desert and promising to try and
get my discharge when I returned to
England I protested I would then return
and marry Maria soon after this the army
marched for Spain the rifles paraded in
the very street where the shop I had so
long worked at was situated and I saw
Maria at the window as our bugle struck
up she waved her handkerchief I returned
the salute and in a half an hour had
forgotten all about her
so much for the soldiers love that I
read that and I said I have to read this
this is to every 18 19 20 and 21 year
old service member out there that you
meet the girl your dreams and you you
think you're gonna do some dumb stuff
mm-hmm
don't do the dumb stuff go back to your
platoon and in a half an hour you'll
forget about because that's what happens
yeah such so much for a soldier's love
back to the book everyman and the rifle
seemed only anxious to get a rap at the
French again on and on we toiled I love
to remember the appearance of that army
as we moved along at this time it was a
glorious sight to see our colors spread
in these fields the men seemed
invincible nothing I fought could have
beaten them now he's talking about a guy
named Cardo he was found to be a most
gallant officer when we were engaged
with the enemy in the field he was
killed whilst fighting bravely in the
Pyrenees and amongst other jewelry he
wore he had a ring on his finger worth
150 guineas as he laid dead on the field
one of our rifle riflemen named or
observed the sparkling gem and
immediately resolved to make a prize of
it the ring however was so firmly fixed
that or could not draw it from the
finger and whipping out his knife cut
the finger off at the joint after the
battle or offered the ring for sale
amongst the officers and on inquiry the
manner in which he had obtained it
transpired or Wisconsin or was in
consequence tried by court martial and
sentenced to receive five hundred lashes
which sentence was carried into
execution there's some significant
corporal punishment going on here with
the with the lashes and that's one of
the cases I mean when you know when
you're executing someone for being drunk
and disorderly you're gonna get some
pretty severe punishment for cutting the
finger
of one year officers so you can steal
their ring yeah back to the book it was
during the heat of the day we were
rather hotly pressed by the enemy after
having advanced somewhat too near their
force give and take is all fair enough
but we were getting more kicks than half
pence as the saying is and their balls
stung us so sharply that the officers
gave the word to fire and retire
doubtless many got a lead and messenger
as they did so which saved them the
unpleasant necessity of retracing their
ground altogether jock Gillespie and
myself wheeled about and obeyed the
order just as we had done so I saw
Gillespie limp along as though someone
had bestowed a violent kick upon his
person however he didn't give up at
first but continued to load and fire and
make off with other skirmishers
skirmishers till we halted and made
another stand for we never went further
from them when once engaged that we
could possibly help I'm gonna read that
again
we continued to load and fire and make
off with other skirmishes till we halted
and made another stand for we never went
further from them when once engaged then
we could possibly help and what that
means is cover move so if you are out on
the battlefield and you get too far away
from the other element where you can no
longer support them you've made a big
mistake yeah so that's why they have
doctrinal terms that mean I am in
supporting distance I won't go further
away from you then then whatever than
where I can't help you
all right now speaking of lashing if
there's another situation here there was
sort of a a ceremony where they were
gathering and standing in the parade
sort of in a town square and somebody
basically through I think like a brick
at is one of the soldiers from one of
the windows that was watching the other
regiment so there's one regiment
standing on the parade field handing out
awards or something the other regiments
sitting up in the various rooms around
looking down and at some point this this
someone Hux a brick down mmm and it hits
the colonel so this guy Liston was the
guy that they they grabbed and they
think it's this guy Liston back to the
book Liston was sentenced to receive
eight hundred lashes the whole brigade
turned out on the occasion and I
remember that the drummers of the 9th
regiment were the inflict errs of the
lash listand Liston received the whole
sentence without a murmur this is a him
talking about is he who goes on to talk
about how this strict discipline about
it and and how it kind of fits in with
the English mentality back to the book
they are strange set the English and so
determined and uncomfortable that they
will have their way if they can think
about that got your soldiers there so
it's a great quality to have right
you're you're determined and
unconquerable but what does that mean I
mean you're gonna have your way if you
can and you can let them they're gonna
see they're gonna get after it maybe
they did way you don't expect indeed
back to the book it indeed it requires
one who has authority in his face as
well as that is back to make them
respect and obey him they see too often
in the instance of sergeant majors that
command does not suit ignorant and
course minded men and that tyranny is
too much used even in the brief
Authority which they have so again he's
going back the fact that even though you
have to have he's talking about the
dichotomy of leadership even though you
have to have
discipline you can't have tyranny back
to the book a soldier I am convinced is
driven often to insubordination by being
worried by these little minded men for
the very the various trifles about which
the gentleman never thinks of tormenting
him so the this the the the little
minded person that harps on these little
trifling things that's what actually
creates insubordination whereas the
gentleman never thinks of tormenting him
with these little things like these
little things don't matter
the and then he goes on to balance this
dichotomy of leadership back to the book
of the moment the severity of the
discipline of our army is relaxed in my
opinion farewell to its efficiency but
for men to be tormented about trifles as
I have seen at many times is often very
injurious to the whole Corps so this is
the perfect talking about the balance of
the dichotomy of leadership if you're
too ultra strict your guys are gonna
rebel against you and if you're not
strict enough if you don't impose enough
discipline they're gonna not have any
control so you've got to balance these
two going forward back to the book war
is a sad blunter of the feelings of men
he said that before he's saying it again
we felt we felt eager to be added again
nay I am afraid we longed for blood as
the cheer of our comrades sounded in our
ears and yet amidst all this softer
feelings occasionally filled the breasts
of those gallant fellows even whilst
they were thirsting for the sight of the
enemy some of the men near me suddenly
recollected as they saw the snow lying
thickly on our pass path that this was
Christmas Eve the recollection soon
spread amongst the men and many talked
of home and scenes upon that night in
the other days of Old England shedding
tears as they spoke of the rillette
relatives and friends never to be seen
again by them as night approached we
became less talkative
the increasing weariness of our limbs
kept our tongues quieter and we were
many of us half asleep as we walked when
suddenly a shout arose in the front that
the French were upon us so guys are
missing home it's Christmas Eve
nice little dusting of snow on the
ground there they have this skirmish
with the French there and how that are
continuing continuing the first March
and if you remember the March that the
that we talked about with Napoleon's
troops going into Russia and back these
guys are under the same basic conditions
of if you want to move the army the
Army's gonna walk hmm back to the book a
sergeant of the night so this so he's
now on this it also he not only the
enforced marching right now they're
starting to retreat they're starting to
they're starting to take heavies and
they start a Ridge a retreat back to the
book a sergeant of the 92nd Highlanders
just about this time fell dead with
fatigue and no one stopped as we passed
to offer him any assistance Knight came
down upon us so let's think about that
and this I highlighted that one but
throughout this book he talks about
people just dying he says they died of
fatigue mm I didn't know what that means
actually maybe they're dehydrated I
don't know but if you think about these
guys who are risking their lives for
each other how exhausted are they that
when someone falls out during this first
march the forced march they just leave
him there
back to the book Knight came down upon
us without our having tasted food or
halted I speak for myself and those
around me all and all night long we
continued this dreadful march men began
to look into each other's faces and ask
the questions ask the question are we
ever to be halted again and many of the
weaker sort were now seen to stagger
make a few desperate efforts and then
fall perhaps to rise no more most of us
had devoured all we cared in or
haversacks
and each end endeavored to catch up
anything we could snatch from a hut or
cottage in our route many even if this
period would have straggled from the
ranks and
Harris had not Crawford held them
together with a firm rain one such bold
and stern commander in the East during a
memorable disaster and that devoted army
had reached its refuge unbroken thus we
staggered on night and day for about
four days before we discovered the
reason of this forced march and they
find out that they're marching actually
towards England they're trying to get
away and this guy that I talked about
Crawford he's pretty significant and
here's a little talk about Crawford
Crawford seemed to sniff the sound of
battle from afar with peculiar feelings
he halted us for a few minutes
occasionally when the distant clamor
became more distinct and his face turned
toward the sound and seemed to light up
and become less Stern it was then indeed
that every poor fellow clutched his
weapon more firmly and wished for a
sight of the enemy before long they had
their wish the enemy's cavalry were on
our skirts that night and as we rushed
out of a small village we turned to Bey
so even though they're retreating
they're still having to fight and this
again this guy Crawford is definitely a
powerful leader back to the book I
remember one evening during the retreat
he detected two men straying away from
the main body it was in the early stage
of that disastrous flight and Crawford
knew and Crawford knew well that he must
do his utmost to keep the division
together he halted the brigade with a
voice of thunder ordered a drumhead
court-martial on the instant and they
were sentenced to a hundred apiece
whilst a hasty trial was taking place
Crawford dismounting from his horse
stood in the midst looking Stern and
angry as a worried bulldog he did not
like retreating at all that man
they march a little bit further and then
back to the book ordering a square to be
formed he spoke to the brigade as well
as I can remember in these words after
having ordered the three before named
men of the 95th to be brought into the
square although he said I should obtain
the good will neither of the officers
nor the men of the brigade here by doing
so I am resolved to punish these three
men according to the sentence awarded
even though the French are at our heels
begin with Daniel how ins so these guys
would look like they were gonna desert
and they got caught and he had a
court-martial on the spot and gonna give
him a hundred lashes or whatever the
number was and even though they're
running and retreating he's all right
we're going wouldn't we're gonna
administer this punishment now even
though it's not popular I gotta do it
back to the book this was indeed no time
to relax and discipline than the general
knew it the men as I said were some of
them becoming careless and ruffianly in
their demeanor whilst others again I saw
with my with the tears falling down
their cheeks from the agony of their
bleeding feet and many were ill with
dysentery and from the effects of bad
food they had got ahold of and devoured
on the road our knapsacks too were a
bitter enemy in this prolonged March
many a man died I'm convinced who would
have borne up well to the end of the
retreat but for the infernal load we
carried on our backs my own knapsack was
my bitterest enemy I felt it pressed me
to the earth almost at times and more
than once felt as if I should die under
its deadly embrace the knapsacks in my
opinion should have been abandoned at
the very commencement of the retrograde
movement as it would have been better to
have lost them altogether
if by such loss we could have saved the
poor fellows who as it was died strapped
to them on the road there was some
difficulty in finding a place to tie
hands up as the Light Brigade carried no
halbert's however they let him to a
slender ash tree which grew near at hand
don't trouble yourselves about tying me
up said how ins folding his arms I'll
take my punishment like a man he did so
without a murmur receiving the whole 300
his wife who was present with us I
remember was a strong hearty Irish woman
so don't worry about tying me up you hit
me 300 times we had a you know they do
the whipping thing with the yeah when
you get out belt yeah do you know do you
remember
Irish John cute all pretty lanky and
real good at jujitsu and he got his blue
belt
mm-hm and he walked through the whipping
hallway to get his belt the gauntlet the
gauntlet he want he walked through the
gauntlet he just walked and stopped at
each person and gave them the
opportunity to give him all they got
yeah that was pretty legit he sounds
like he sounds like he sounds like my
boy Howard's right here more about
Crawford right here this is classic
there they're getting to a river they
got across the river on their retreat
back to the book presently he spied an
officer who to save himself from being
wet through I supposed and wearing a
damp pair of breeches for the remainder
of the day had mounted on the back of
one of his men the sight of such a piece
of effeminacy was enough to raise the
collar of the general and in a very
short time he was plunging and splashing
through the water after them both
put him down sir put him down I desired
to put that officer down instantly and
the soldier in an instant I daresay lost
dropping his burden like a hot potato
into the stream continued his progress
through returned back sir said Crawford
to the officer and go through the water
like the others I will not allow my
officers to ride upon the men's back
through the rivers all must take their
share alike here you can just go ahead
and note that
is how to lead that's just the that's a
metaphorical and literal example maybe
I'm gonna ride on the back of my
enlisted man so that I can stay dry what
a savage I think that that guy should
have gotten some lashes back to the book
general Crawford was indeed one of the
few men who is apparently created for
the command during such dreadful scenes
as we were familiar with in this retreat
he seemed an Iron Man nothing daunted
him nothing turned him from his purpose
war was his very element and toil and
danger seemed to call forth an
increasing determination to surmount
them now they are continuing to march
and again you it's it's a story we've
heard many times on here and how harsh
foot marches can be and at this point
rifleman Harris he doesn't think he's
gonna make it
mm-hm and he's fading fast he's marching
with a guy named Brooks they're kind of
broken up into pairs to try and stay
together a little bit and he's trying to
maintain back to the book I remember sir
Dudley Hill passing me on a mule this
day he wore a Spanish straw hat and had
his cloak on he looked back when he had
passed and addressed me Harris said he I
see you cannot keep up he peered very
sorry for me free knew me well you must
do your best he said my man and keep up
with us or you will fall into the hands
of the enemy as the day wore on I grew
weaker and weaker and at last despite
all of my efforts I saw the main body
leave me hopelessly in the lurch Brooks
himself was getting weaker too he saw it
was of little use to urge me on and at
length accenting to my repeated request
to be left behind he hurried on as well
and he was able without a word of
farewell I now soon sank down in the
Road and lay beside another man who had
also fallen was apparently dead and who
might recognized as one of our sergeants
named Taylor whilst we lay exhausted in
the road the rearguard which was now
endeavoring to drive on the stragglers
approached and a sergeant of the rifles
came up and stopped and look at us he
dressed himself to me and ordered me to
rise but I told him it was a useless for
him to trouble himself about me as I was
unable to move a step further whilst he
was urging me to endeavour to rise up
the officer in command of the rearguard
also stepped up the name of this officer
was lieutenant Cox he was a brave and
good man and observing that the sergeant
was rough in his language and manner
towards me he silenced him and bade the
guard proceed and leave me let him die
quietly Hicks he said to the sergeant I
know him well he's not a man to lie here
if he could get on I'm sorry Harris
Harris he said to see you reduced to
this for I fear there is no help to be
had now he then moved on after his men
and left me to my fate lot different
than never leave a man behind you've
actually got people just saying eh
you're not gonna make it
though I can see you're not gonna make
it I know you're a tough guy and if
you're not if you're not walking right
now there's an got nothing for you now
he lays there for a while and he
actually once he rests for a while he
regains a little bit of strength he
eventually crawls to a house gets in the
house and gets a little bit of food and
gets a little bit of it and I would love
to say water but it isn't get water he
gets food and wine and he recovers
somewhat he pretty much recovers sleeps
for a while wakes up recovers and now he
can now he can walk again and what do
you think
would happen now like in a case as
similar to this as possible you know it
but just now where I can't make it what
do you do carry him yeah you mean you
try and carry him of course other guys
yeah and I mean it's horrible to think
of these situations where if you know we
have to move these all these men and to
sit there if we start let's let's weigh
this you'd have to weigh this if we try
and carry all of our wounded out well
none of us are gonna live right so that
that's what the that's the situation
that they're likely facing hey you're
either gonna get out of here yourself
and people don't understand how hard it
is to carry a Down man it's very very
difficult to carry a down man especially
across terrain and you know sometimes in
wrestling practice you pick up and you
pick up your partner and you do a couple
laps right and yeah you know it's all
good you're on this nice smooth surface
you guys cooperate the guys cooperating
that's not just dead weight it's yeah
when you start carrying bodies around
it's really really difficult yeah so you
don't it's not a one-to-one either so if
one guys down you can it's not just one
person carries that guy yeah it actually
has to be two or sometimes three we have
gear on yeah and we have methods of
carrying guys I mean what I can carry
you a little while right but after a
little while you know be that 500 meters
a thousand meters you're not gonna be
you're free free and also your combat
ineffective you can't you can't utilize
your weapon properly not for not for any
length of time so you know in a
situation like this that's the decision
that these leaders are making is hey
guess what if we don't just keep walking
we're gonna get overrun the French are
gonna catch us and we're all gonna die
yeah so Harris ain't got nothing for you
so in contempt like now we'll say but if
there was a circumstance like that where
we're gonna lose more guys if we bring
this guy with us or one big luxury that
we have now is we have air air support
yeah
so oh the enemy wants to keep coming at
us cool we'll sit here and call drop
bombs on them all day situations like
that have happened over and over again
and
modern wars in Iraq and Afghanistan
where small elements are out there in
the field they're about to get overrun
and the aircraft and air air fire air
power comes in and completely saves the
day and keeps the enemy at bay for
extended periods of time
yeah so we have a option yeah another
option but in the cap I guess it
altima be a hypothetical then then a
case why pathetically even then you got
to put someone in that situation and see
what they're gonna do and that's a
decision you got to make as a leader and
on the spot yeah I mean you d be
weighing all these micro micro facets
never happening how far away are the bad
guys yeah well how many of them are
there do I have reinforcements coming is
there any terrain I could take is there
what you know what can I do how many
people are down yeah you have to weigh
all these things out and make a decision
it's gonna be a hard decision
yeah for sure I mean so you don't put
like the the concept or should I say
like the action of at least trying to
bring the guy with you ahead of like
other guys lives so a circumstance like
this where you have there you don't have
any continued you don't have any support
you don't have any other options it's
either other guys die or that we leave
this guy behind the fact that you tried
to bring the guy doesn't Trump like the
lives of other guys where you if the
decision is to be made where it's
understood like other guys would have
died if we didn't leave this guy here
that would be okay it's not gonna be
okay and you're gonna have to live with
one horrible right thought or the other
right the the thing that's powerful
about we're not gonna leave everything
anyone behind but it's powerful about
that is if that's your if that's your
default mode you didn't fall mode is to
fight and that's what that's what that's
what we trained that's when I say we I
mean like America trainers we're not
gonna leave you behind and so when
that's your go-to attitude that's your
go-to attitude and all the thoughts
about hey we'll weigh it out and also
there's like no yeah we're gonna fight
we're gonna kill everyone and we're
we're gonna do everything we can do to
bring everyone back that's what we do
yeah and that is a powerful thing yeah
man these are savage times these are
savage times savage times going so like
I said he does recover though luckily
before the French get to him he recovers
enough to get out start walking again
and he talks a little bit how he was
clinging and he was clinging to survival
yeah back to the book
it is however indeed astonishing how a
man clings to life I am certain that had
I lain down at this period I should have
found my last billet on the spot I sank
upon suddenly I heard a shout in the
front which was prolonged in a sort of
hub hub even the stragglers whom I saw
dotting the road in front of me seemed
to have caught something like hope and
as the poor fellow's now reached the top
of the hill were ascending I heard an
occasional exclamation of joy the first
note of the sort I had heard for many
days when I reached the top of the hill
the thing spoke for itself there far
away in our front the English shipping
lay in sight it's a view had indeed
acted like a restorative to our force
and the men at the prospect of the
termination of such a march had plucked
up spirit for a last effort fellows who
like myself seemed to hardly have
strength in their legs to creep up the
ascent seemed now to have picked up a
fresh pair to get down with such as hope
to us poor mortals so they obviously see
the sea the ships and that inspires them
and they start moving a little bit
faster back to the book there was I
recollect a man of the name of bell of
the rifles who had been during this day
holding a sort of creeping race with me
we had passed and re-passed each other
as our strength served Bell was a rather
discontented fellow at the best of times
but during this retreat he did give
full-scope to his ill-temper cursing the
hour he was born and wishing his mother
had strangled him when he came into the
world in order to have saved him from
his present toil he had not now spoken
for some time and the site of the
English shipping had apparently a very
beneficial effect upon him he burst into
tears as he stood and looked at it
Harris he said if it pleases God to let
me reach those ships
I swear never to utter a bad or
discontented word again appreciation and
he did make it to the ships and Harris
rifleman Harris made it to the ships and
they got embarked on those ships and
they sailed back to England for a few
days and then get off the English shore
and then finally back to the book one
fine morning we received orders to
disembark and our poor bare feet once
more touched English ground the
inhabitants flocked down to the beach to
see us as we did so and they must have
been a good deal surprised at the
spectacle we presented our beards were
long and ragged almost all were without
shoes and stockings many had their
clothes and accoutrements and fragments
with their heads suave than old rags and
our weapons were covered with rust
whilst not a few had now from toil and
fatigue become quite blind let not the
reader however think that now we we were
to be despised as soldiers long marches
inclement weather and want of food had
done their work upon us but we were
perhaps better than we appeared as the
sequel showed under the gallant Crawford
we had made some tremendous marches and
even gal'd our enemy so severely making
good our retreat but our comrades in
adversity who had retired by the other
road under general more turned
they there and showed the enemy that the
English soldier is not to be beaten even
under the most adverse circumstances the
field of death and slaughter the March
the bivouac and the retreat are no bad
places in which to judge men I have had
some opportunities of judging them in
all these situations and I should say
that the British are amongst the most
splendid soldiers in the world give them
fair play and they are unconquered ball
for my own part I can only say that I
enjoyed life more whilst on active
service than I have ever done since and
as I sit at work in my shop in Richmond
Street Soho I look back upon that
portion of my time spent in the fields
of the peninsula has the only part
worthy of remembrance it is at such
times that scenes long past come back
upon my mind as if they had taken place
but yesterday I remember even the
appearance of some regiments engaged and
comrades long moulded to dust I see
again performing the acts of heroes
acts
of heroes and I think it's safe to call
riflemen Benjamin Randall Harris a hero
as well and at the same time I think
it's important to remember that these
these men these heroes they're not
superheroes like we see today in movies
they don't wear a cape they don't have
any superhuman strength they have no
special powers what they do have is they
have will the will to fight the will to
drive on the will to live the will to
win and I think that's the superpower
then it never ceases to amaze me these
aren't normal people riflemen Harris was
a normal guy like us but when called
upon to march they march and we called
upon to fight they fight and when called
upon to rise up and overcome they do
just that they rise up and overcome and
that shows us that we can do the same
thing in the Fallon in the challenges
that we face we can do the same thing
rise
and overcome and I think that's all I've
got for tonight
so echo perhaps if you could let people
know how they can support themselves and
maybe if they want to support this
podcast as well it's crazy how these
marches right brutal yeah
and this is I I don't know I mean uh
from what I can remember the worst
wasn't one he's especially hardly talked
about with no shoes shoes their shoes
probably just fall off within the first
you know a little bit and then they're
walking with no shoes or barely any
shoes or whatever
crying straight up just from the March
by the way yeah not the not the war or
anything like that where the March is
yet just as big of an enemy he said his
pack was his biggest enemy he had
literally though yeah the kind word guys
are stressed I don't know killings
killing them so we we just got back from
Utah obviously mmm and you know after
every we're doing that training where
you know we brief debrief record on
exercise brief and then you know we walk
back in for trekking so okay so echo
I'll just tell PB s-- people have no
idea what you're talking about which is
fine
echo we just confront did a FTX field
training exercise with a company we were
in Utah we brought echo out so that he
could get some footage and whatnot in so
the semester each document so we're in
the field but we're doing basically
urban combat with a group of let's call
them regular people business people that
are learning leadership through
experiential environments yeah it's an
interesting it's like a it's like a kind
you know how if you don't communicate
with someone effectively writings fall
apart right right or if you don't you
know yeah it's like I know exactly what
you're on out situation
but this is like a condensed version of
that and yes so if you don't communicate
with someone during an FTX it do you
know within like 30 seconds that
something just went wrong yeah and now
we're getting shot in the face with with
airsoft rifles yeah yeah it's so it's
really fun to watch from the outside
yeah cuz you see it and I've been to
another one too and yeah you see it's
right and it's interesting how in the
beginning it's like it's almost
impossible you don't know
and immediately communication breaks
down immediately yeah and then towards
the end you start to see people
communicating getting it you know like
are you kind of a lot of them but you
got to over communicate yeah for sure
and but the more you do that the more
effective it is you know it's so crazy
it a lot it is and I don't know if you
remember Dave saying this Dave told them
he said Jocko just told you the mistakes
that you're gonna make you told you what
you're going to do yeah and you're gonna
do it yeah sure enough a lot of single
one of them the funniest was the one
individual that said they came up with a
plan for something and we said you know
you're risking get a blue a blue on blue
there yeah and she said she said listen
I understand what you're saying but it's
not like we're gonna walk in there and
start shooting each other yeah that's
not gonna happen
and and sure enough that very girl was
in a stressful situation and they
entered a building from two different
sides at the same time and sure enough
she dusted one for her one of her
teammates yeah and it was you know it's
one of those things yeah I said hey
remember what you said yesterday she
said Ye oh yeah I remember
so Justin and I had the luxury of seeing
it from the outside I can feel it though
yeah in a different situation position
than me anyway the point is um so in the
terrain there was where the field and
where you were you actually do the field
training part of it um is like what
would you say 100 200 yards away from
the breach where you do the brief sandy
breeze is about 400 yards yeah yeah so
it's 300 yards if you're doing it again
in the
we're going brief exercise debrief brief
exit you know so kind of all day really
so and this was a situation where there
was a hill and rocky you know here so
I'm walking right and I have my camera
the whole time
and it's not it's later than my other
camp but you know it's something and so
I'm walking back and forth all day all
day where my feet are starting to get
like kind of tired more tired than
normal and I'm thinking every but every
single time though every single time I'm
thinking this is nothing compared to
what you guys would I need everything
yeah you know how nothing it was I
didn't that death thought didn't even go
across my mind at all in any way shape
or form you don't see what that is while
I'm walking this was like me after
lunchtime I'm thinking I'm seeing you
guys and everyone's cruising and I'm
thinking is everyone trying to act like
this isn't like kind of I literally
didn't think of it until you said this
to me right now yeah the biggest
I was I was totally acting like there's
nothing no I wasn't imagining I was
gonna get brother toy on a lot of stuff
that's good and it helps know what it is
but the fact is do you do actually
better when you pretend that it doesn't
bother yes that's insane yeah but gotta
remember that night in day night at
night and it's sort of acting all tired
except yeah showing everyone yeah it's
true
oh but nonetheless the fact is it wasn't
nothing it wasn't nothing I felt it and
you know so I'm as funny I'm looking at
you guys I'm like hey I wonder if these
guys are you know but no one said
anything no nobody said damn these
tracks are getting long that's because
they were 400 meters bro but nonetheless
so every time I feel anything like that
I think of like you guys first and you
guys are doing it in like crazy heat to
gear and like all this stuff and I think
of this kind eyes
these King guys yeah riflemen Harris
riflemen Harris feet all tore up
starving starving starving no sleet no
water no water and people are trying to
kill you oh yeah yeah so that's the
point man is if these guys can rise and
come that they know what figure your
personal potential yeah right yeah
think of it think of what more you could
do yeah
I have lovers you a little bit I just
saw them looking bothersome yeah yeah
that looked like it made some dope
videos though about to make a huge
excuse right now to which I don't even
know if it's an excuse but it's a factor
where these like hard actual hard times
kind of call on you to exercise this
kind of will you know and I think a lot
of times we're not like hard times don't
call on us like this anyway I mean hard
times do you know but you know what
though you know what though
it you should but I mean technically and
potentially you should be able to
exercise as much will as it takes
really now when you consider kind of the
limits you know these are the limits I
was interesting this is that this is one
of the stories where the guy's like I'm
done yeah he said okay I'm done guys are
saying hey if you stay here you're gonna
die yeah I cannot move anymore then you
think about you know what what point are
you at when you cannot save your own
life by walking you can't walk can't
take another step and he came back from
that yeah yeah and they do a really good
job in illustrating it cuz he or talking
about it where cuz he mentioned the no
shoes thing
yeah few times yeah you did but again I
bet if yeah yeah he does a great job but
you can't even begin to yeah can't even
begin to really get the point across
yeah good way it is as the the leader I
was talking to a guy the other day that
when two buds and didn't make it through
yeah and I known him for a while and I
just said like hey man well you know
you're a good dude you know what why did
you why did you quit and he said you
know it just sucked mmm and I was like
okay but didn't you know it was gonna
suck and he said yeah I knew was gonna
suck but at the same time you know I
watched on
and I thought to myself okay yeah that's
gonna suck he said so I thought I
understood how it was gonna suck yeah
but I didn't understand how I was gonna
say yeah I was there I said this really
sucks and he quit and again a good dude
that that I'm kind of you know thinking
myself why I'm trying to figure out why
people quit yeah and that was what he
said he said much like we're saying like
as much as you could imagine and if they
save yourself all man yeah but I think I
could make that one more step you don't
know yeah you're knowing so you've been
dehydrated having people trying to shoot
you cleaning up your buddy's brains off
your jacket for weeks months on end
you're dehydrated and now you have no
shoes no stockings and your marks you're
doing a forced march on this road for
this but they March for days without
stopping what even is that no yeah yeah
that's it I mean this kind of that's not
to mention like no medical care no no
like no one's coming to save you you do
not know it you know it's really jacked
up it's think about this think if you
have an ingrown toenail right right like
like a little thing that is bob it
actually bothers you in actual life yeah
think if you had that here or you have a
or you have let's say you got a sprained
ankle yeah a bad sprained ankle mm-hmm I
sprained my ankle really bad before sure
you can't walk on it well now you don't
have a choice you need to walk on it or
you die
think about the little things that are
that caused you an inconvenience right
now think about what an inconvenience
that is in this situation thing about
you little infection in your fingers you
know your finger your you ever had one
of those little stupid like where your
fingernail is get a little connection
there yeah yeah think about that uh yeah
and that you'd have no medicine you
don't have any way of your that things
are gonna turn into a giant infection
yeah you die there's the little little
tiny things that annoy you are dick will
kill you back in the day
check yeah so what we have to do is
prepare for these hard times do you have
any advice on how we could help prepare
ourselves for these hard times on top
referencing these scenarios I reference
your guys scenario like basically
everything that you guys guys tell me
and talk about like how it's super hot
how you don't sleep as much I'm not
talking about them talking like in
Ramadi like all these stuff I can't
imagine that helps totally helps mm-hmm
that's good
because it helps me to think about
rifleman Harris yeah for sure
- speaking of help speaking - help help
being yourself so you're just in the way
this is kind of a dichotomy here cuz you
know like when your joints get sore I'm
talking joining them for a real quick
that you can be supreme luxury yeah you
know man Harris we had krill enjoy
warfare
who knows maybe wouldn't a stop that day
that time this pre luxury yeah supreme
luxury where now it's like hey my joints
I'm getting older my joints can hurt I
don't have I can't work out at the gym
you know at my leisure as good let me
take some joint warfare you know improve
my comfort while I work out function for
sure function but comfort has a lot to
do with it
working out with sore joints is way less
comfortable then not sore joint yeah I'm
gonna say though there's exercises that
you cannot do when you when your joints
aren't ready to rock and roll yeah so
you can push yourself harder and be
better prepared for the hard times if
you're working correctly now if your
joints aren't working correctly
yeah that's it that kind of me and there
also is no like concession there's no
there's no reason to say hey my joints
being less healthy is it good is fine
mmm is good that's a good thing you know
so you have a choice shouldn't should I
maintain or improve this joint my joint
health the health of my body including
but not limited to joints or should I
not the decision should never be
I'm not never be I think this was my
opinion anyway so the point is so Jacque
with some supplements joint solace for
your joints to me best kind of
supplements as someone who with a level
head now as far as supplements goes go
I think the joint for your joints you
know bones maybe stuff that's gonna be
structure structure role yeah structural
support because again and I said I said
this before like if you're like going
for a super cool protein powder a lot of
people that say hey what's a good
protein powder here's the thing you
don't steak like how much protein do you
like not get to need supplemental
protein well people you know people want
that cause getting the convenience
that's why people like those very very
few I'm gonna make one that's gonna be
both convenient and tasty yeah and good
yeah
there you go nonetheless that's cool I'm
not saying that's a bad thing
I'm saying as far as like the importance
of focusing on a supplement the most
benefit okay so you found a missing your
convenience that really for sure that's
supplementing protein you're
supplementing convenience nothing wrong
with that nothing wrong with that we've
got a lot to do I understand
but as far as like the would he call it
the hierarchy of supplementation change
Jordan B Peters and supplements are the
house of supplements the juice krill oil
Omega threes like these kinds of things
that help you directly that's the that's
the main ones anyway so your point in
all this is supplements legit
supplements super krill oil Jocko super
krill is what's called Skrill oil free
joints and joint warfare where do you
get them or Jin mean dot-com kid Thank
You Brown I'm telling you these I feel
like you're drawing this out way to
watch
if I was doing this to be like a if you
want to have good healthy joints get
some krill oil super krill and get some
joint warfare from Orange and Maine calm
em a I and II yeah but and then we'd be
good we'd be moving on the next thing ya
know I dig it and I want to talk about
the hierarchy remember and this makes
sense this is relevant get all serious
review point because you're not doing
I'm gonna prove it no because bat out of
your element again again when I was will
say 23 mm-hmm take some phosphate
something yeah so what if someone
listening or group people listening yeah
who have that same mindset right and
it's not it's not because I knew both
things I just I just didn't know okay so
I'm gonna say it now now we know yeah
well that's good if there's someone that
doesn't know that maybe they turned this
off like eight minutes ago maybe maybe
not or maybe they're more educated now
and maybe pull them there now they're
looking into the joint situation that's
what I think is happening that's my
opinion
thank you that's my prediction I'm sure
Twitter will let us know anyway or
Jemaine calm on the top click labs
actually it's right in the front page I
keep forgetting this trailer front page
boom supercro jock super crow and join
Warford get on it there's also some G's
and rash guards people had been asking
me years now what geese should I get I
started you - what geese should I get we
know now we know now hundred percent all
made in America from the cotton from the
seeds of the cotton planted harvested
process excited about seeds did you see
yeah well that's an exciting thing I'm
just saying yeah if you're into that
kind of thing but nonetheless you know
heat makes it in Maine formulate to the
fabric boom geese other stuff too by the
way
clothing pete has more of like a stylish
kind of twist on his clothing yeah in
fact I always who was it Oh Dave Burke
yeah we're in Utah yeah had the origin
the hoodie yeah and the hoodie has like
I don't know if you know this can stuff
like there's certain cuts of like duties
and so it's like you know what my
gutters Excel yeah yeah see it goes
beyond that no rather yes it does anyway
Mike you know it's noticeable for people
who want to notice it notice that I'm
gonna dance girl did Oh what you think
that's a good like that's a good come on
Dave yeah it's something it's not
nothing
Duncan nonetheless it's all made in
America and there's a little stylish
twist if you're there to notice if you
care to notice has some fashion style
baked in there if you don't notice you
don't notice because you you ever were
that you were the hoodie right
functional yeah warm to get me warm I'm
not used to 19 degrees like it wasn't
you talk yeah you weren't leash to that
I don't think I was but I had that
helped you guys had these biggest
gore-tex jackets nonetheless all the
stuff on Origin main comm is made in
America from Caesar the cotton all the
way to the final garment you're wearing
yep yep good one check out the stuff on
there good way to support also in your
fitness routines if you want to expand
out of like just basic a bench squat
burpees deadlifts what a basic ones if
you want expand do some like cool
interesting stuff on it calm slash choco
go there they got some cool fitness gear
kettlebells which are they got all the
kettlebells including the artistic ones
those are cool I think those are all the
ones I have just artistic ones jerk
makes it fun ER put a little twist on it
and you can mix up your workout as far
as creativity which keeps it fun for
some people not choco some people though
if you vary the workout like new
movements funk new functional movements
if you will you're more likely to stick
with it stay on the paten make the path
enjoyable sometimes don't just neglect
the enjoyability
of your workout
if you want on it calm slash drop a
really good fitness gear on there you
know check it out see what you like and
get something also when you are buying
the book recollections of rifleman
Harris I'm gonna make it easy for you we
have made it easy for you go on the
website Jocko podcast.com on the top man
uses books from episodes boom there's a
list of all the books by episode click
through there to get it it takes it
Amazon and both good way to support if
you want to do some other shopping while
you're on there like what lawn mowers
golf clubs golf clubs podcast equipment
recently a lot of people been hitting me
up seeing him I'm gonna start a podcast
what's the equipment you know I should
get they asked me that too but I asked
echo yeah no wonder I just talk yes you
press record yes and I got the equipment
so I had that knowledge and excited
about that are we so hey having
knowledge is better than not having the
knowledge in whatever regard nonetheless
if you're gonna buy podcast equipment
carry on do that stuff but yeah click
through that's good good way to support
also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already on stitcher itunes
obviously Google Play Spotify
confirmed know it seems weird that I
didn't know that for sure it seems real
weird here's the thing so many things
that weird we need to talk about it for
a bit I guess yeah you know what you're
right it's just me expressing myself
look all you got to know Spotify
confirmed tubes out there confirmed it
to me yeah and that's really the good
thing about people interacting yes it is
you learn a lot about yourself in your
own situation they know things that you
don't know oh yeah I have things that I
don't know cuz they're detached and they
have different expertise by the way in a
lot of ways most ways anyway subscribe
if you haven't already also subscribed
on YouTube there's excerpts on there if
you don't want to listen or if you
don't necessarily watch the whole
episode video version of this podcast
you can just get little excerpts taking
share watch or even come back to that's
a big look
yeah we've put out so much that it's too
much people can't absorb it all the
first time around
yeah wait what do you mean like the
whole episode you mean oh no you what
was on episode 63 right people people
don't remember that thing maybe so you
just like jiu-jitsu you go listen you
learn it again and now you know it's
more recognizable yeah so it's like
drilling a little bit yes I'm gonna come
back I'm gonna drill some more it yeah
and some you know how like certain
things just apply to you more like if
your your advice on I don't know College
that's easy when you remember about how
to approach college like crash college
you would ever come it's gonna apply to
me more if I'm actually in college you
know let's just apply that to other
things in life would you actually do you
can't for sure but that's gonna apply to
me directly will say oh you know more
than maybe the next guy so that kind of
stuff where that one I want to remember
okay I'm gonna come back to that one if
I can constantly remind myself of the
things that directly apply to me you can
be more it's gonna be more beneficial
rather than just listen to all the
podcasts and hoping you remember each
one nonetheless point there is that's it
that's a good reason to subscribe to the
YouTube channel so if you in fact if the
excerpts or some excerpts resonate with
you you got them there at your
fingertips and you can share also
Jacques was the store it's called
Jacques store Jaakko store calm that's
the URL there Barret that's where you
can get if you want shirts you don't
even know what URL Ozzy anymore of
course they do do you think so I think
that's common language no actually no I
think you're right actually on the
website website yeah the website where's
URL stand for I don't think I knew no
I'm actually not it okay yeah but you
knew I I knew what it meant I don't know
what it stands for you know you know I
don't know Universal something ask you
I know it's probably not even Universal
Jake Charles nonetheless it's Jocko
the website is Jocko store.com I know
not that creative but easy to remember
that's where you can get the shirts
hoodies rash guards compression rash
guards if you will for various
activities where you maintaining range
of motion jiu-jitsu specifically in my
opinion hoodies on their hoodies all the
hoodies they're the same design but
though they're the heavy ones people
hasn't been asking me like are these the
heavy ones or where's the heavy hoodies
with all the ones we saw like the the
non heavy ones we'll call them I've not
they're heavy yeah the first kind of
iteration exactly what those were all
sold out
they sold out last year yeah and so I
did another iteration with your request
for the heaviest third they're the
heaviest one actually I think there
might be some industrial heavier one
baby no because I think that was then
yeah I don't know I forget nonetheless
these are the heavy ones confirmed
double comfort also some women's stuff
on there I think I'm gonna add a few
things before Christmas on the store
that'd be good so if you want keep your
eyes on that that's a good way to
support if you want something get
something check my also psychological
warfare if you know what that is until
it's an album with tracks
Jaakko talking on these tracks basically
you listen to them when you are you know
on the path will say on the map and you
get moments of weakness days of weakness
you know those you're not feeling like
it you think you know how you always
talk about like it doesn't matter if you
feel like it or not you just do it
yeah okay okay so and I respect that and
that's where we all want ab wanna beat
we all want to be there but for some of
us it's not like that 100% of the time
sometimes when you really don't feel
like it sometimes when I really don't
you like it I just don't do it man
sometimes it could be honest we'll put
on psychological warfare and you'll do
it yes it's like a spot you know
especially a spare it's like a
no-brainer like really easy when you
you're like contemplating like I could
either I could just do this tomorrow
right and you start making deals with
yourself you ever do that no deals with
myself is that the weak part of Italy
you don't it's so straight up Jocko no
deals Jocko like I don't feel like it I
feel like it whatever that actually
makes me gay naughty I get pissed at
myself yourself if I start leaning
towards like oh maybe I just won't do
anything no oh really really oh so how
it is yeah okay cool I'm gonna go smash
you know it's real funny
I would that doesn't surprise I've
witnessed that with you like we'll be
talking like I don't know if we can kind
of do that then you get this sort of
look this coming away about you kind of
like the weight that I'm talking about
as uh
Echo's going on vacation and he's gonna
be gone for a couple weeks and I've been
real busy with all kinds of stuff and we
were talking about if we'd be able to
actually get all these podcasts done and
I didn't think we could do it and so I
said hey echo you know what you have to
take you know no no podcast for a few
weeks and then then I said actually like
a day went by milk and I said I said
echo text that said uh actually we're
gonna do it yeah and do we record all
the podcasts I'm gonna prep for mall
we're gonna have an all-nighter and
we'll just get it done
bring some Red Bull and get something
bring some chocolate white tea yeah oh
what was interesting about that is when
you said that you had this kind of tone
of like dang term it like we gotta take
a break we got to take a break after two
years by the way yeah every single week
by the way we got to take a break that's
what you said yeah and right when and I
was like cool I dig it no I mean I'm not
saying good I'm saying cool I totally
understand and you
what that makes sense HBO big company
takes huge breaks everybody takes huge
breaks everybody thinks oh yeah
and you're over here two years in no
brakes no brakes no matter what okay so
there come a time when we are forced to
for some reason yeah that's kind of part
of the point brah so I'm like cool I dig
it I totally understand Jocko and when I
said that that's when your face kind of
shifted like tiny you went into your own
world and did I just say that like it's
almost like you sort of got mad real
subtle
but it was there and I was like oh we're
not taking a break I know he's gonna
come back nonetheless and I'm sure that
okay so I dig it but back to
psychological warfare if you need a spot
or even want a spot with those times
that you're like maybe I'll skip the
workup maybe I'll slip in the dead
minute just listen to any track and the
track is labeled you know where if you
can skip on the diet it's like
sugar-coated like wait what is a sugar
quarter lives but it's something
something's sugar-coated like sure yeah
so you listen to that and then what's
good is it's not some inspirational yeah
you can do it it's not that it's like
pretty pragmatic I hear to do that no
here's the thing though you just by
nature either your tone of voice kind of
kind of like by happenstance inserts
that concept in it so it's kind of a
double-double thing as it turns out but
primarily it's just it's a pragmatic
thing think about think about this
logical stuff and then at the end of the
track you kind of conclude that oh yeah
it's it's gonna get after yeah exactly
right that's what psychological warfare
is it is on iTunes Amazon music Google
Play wherever you get mp3s mp3's true
story good way to support also you get
Chaka white tea and if you're having
trouble deadlifting less than 8,000
pounds if you get chocolate tea that
will be solved immediately and your your
deadlift will then be 8,000 pounds
including Jordan V Peterson who can now
left 8,000 pounds he broke through his
7,000 pounds yep barrier barrier books I
got some books way the warrior kid
number one don't let your kid be a Wimpy
Kid why would you do that why would you
let your neighbor's kid be a Wimpy Kid
why would you do that
get him on the path way the warrior kid
path stronger faster smarter better get
some extreme ownership the new edition
is out and thanks to you all because we
added questions your questions from this
podcast into an appendix inside not
every question but a bunch of them a
good amount so they're in there there's
also new forward and some new color
pictures color pictures interesting yeah
because I don't like color pictures I
said no that caught on me they said well
this is more premium I said no black and
white is free music gifts so anyways if
you want to see what I look like in
color then you can get the book but to
to offset that I said okay fine you want
to put color pictures in there make the
whole book black so that's they did the
whole book black and that was that and
speaking of black also the discipline
equals freedom field manual is available
and I talked about that tagline that the
publisher wanted to have like Veeam this
book is a superb gift for the holiday
season and I told them no the tagline is
there's no better gift than discipline
that's the truth you know it's actually
true if you could give someone the gift
of discipline would you not be giving
them the best gift in life yes now you
can actually give them the gift of
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
so you can do that
now this is important as people keep
asking me the field manual audio version
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
is it is also on iTunes Amazon music
Google Play other mp3 platforms it's
available right now it is not on audible
audible is not with tracks we wanted an
album with tracks that's why we did it
this way
for something on top of the books and
the podcast if you need leadership
training and execution at your business
or with your team you can contact our
leadership consulting company to me it's
JP Danelle life Bob and Dave Burke info
national on front comm and if you have
questions for us or you have answers for
us a couple questions I asked today you
can communicate with us on the interwebs
on Twitter on Instagram and on echo is
that echo Charles and I am at Jocko
willing and to the service men and women
out there right now holding the line
slogging through the mud and the heat
and the danger and the fear thank you
for defending us and our freedoms and to
the police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
other first responders thanks for living
the life that you live which allows us
to live the life we live and to everyone
else that's listening just remember that
you might not be wearing a cape you
might not have any magic powers but you
have the ultimate power and that is
human will the power to March to fight
to overcome and to get after it so until
next time this is echo and Jocko